-Welcome back, everybody.
We are here with Mandy Moore.
Her new album --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Her new album, "In Real Life,"
is out on Friday.
I want to quickly mention that
you sang a song on
"This Is Us" a few weeks ago.
And the next day, it went to
number 1 on the iTunes chart.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that.
♪♪
-It's really bizarre.
-How fun is that?
-So much fun.
I mean, the power of television
is alive and real.
Yes.
-It's real. Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah. I remember, growing up,
I loved "Family Ties,"
and there was this song
by Billy Vera & The Beaters,
"At This Moment."
That was a song that they
played, and then --
It was just a song, and then
I guess this guy, Billy Vera,
recorded it a couple years
before, and it wasn't a hit.
Then they aired it on
"Family Ties,"
and everyone is like,
"What is that song?"
And it went to number 1.
-I love those stories.
-It's the best.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations to you, bud.
-Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is "This Is Us" get you back
into music and recording?
-Yeah, so, that was something
that, unbeknownst to me,
when I got cast,
Dan Fogelman decided to make
my character's backstory
music-related,
and it kind of sent me
into the studio
very early on
in the first season.
And I remember I sang this
Little Feat-Linda Ronstadt song
called "Willin'."
And I had a band with me,
and I was like, "I miss this.
I remember this feeling."
I hadn't made a record in,
you know,
five, six, seven years
at that point.
And it activated something
in me again that --
it just pushed me
to start writing
and get into the studio
and make a record.
Yeah.
-Yeah. "In Real Life"
is out on Friday.
-Yes, sir.
-You're going on tour.
-I am!
-I mean, June 10th,
you're in Atlanta, in Georgia.
You're at, June 15th,
Webster Hall here in New York.
-Yeah!
-The Ryman.
I saw you're in D.C.
at the 9:30 Club, June 14th.
-Yeah!
-Love the 9:30 club.
-Me too.
-Look at all these dates.
So, this is a family affair?
-I know. A family affair.
My husband, Taylor,
is in my band.
My brother-in-law,
Griffin, is the drummer.
Gus is coming.
-The baby's coming.
This is like --
-It's a Partridge Family.
-The Partridge Family.
I was going to say!
You guys are all on
the bus together.
-Yep, we are.
-♪ Come on, get happy ♪
-The Gus Bus.
That's what we call it.
I mean, congratulations.
I mean, this is going to be fun.
This is gonna be a fun tour.
-It's an adventure. We'll see.
-Yeah, no.
I mean, this is --
You're performing tonight.
Which song are you
performing tonight?
-"In Real Life."
-"In Real Life" is tonight.
-Yeah.
-The title track.
And you got some good pics here
of the baby on the inside.
-Yes. Got to include
the family in there.
-You got to include the family.
-Yeah.
I wrote this whole record
during the pandemic
and when I was pregnant,
so it's, like, filled with
songs about impending parenthood
and, you know,
thinking of my own childhood and
trying to make sense of
what was happening in the world.
But it was very cathartic
to write it.
-I love it.
Mandy's album, "In Real Life,"
is out this Friday.
And you can watch the final
season of "This Is Us"
Tuesdays at 9:00 p.m. on NBC.